[Music]  for the spicy sauce sliced anchovies and  garlic next dried chillies great for  keeping the covers at a hint of heat on  demand  [Music]  then add the anchovy oil to hot pan and  fry the chopped ingredients  add half cherry tomatoes chopped black  olives and salty capers cook to combine  the flavors  in a separate pan ball dry spaghetti  another great store cupboard staple when  the pasta is tender but still firm drain  add to the sauce with a splash of the  water it's full of starch which gives a  great silky consistency  then season with pepper and topless  basil  packed with big bold flavors and ready  in under 20 minutes past with smartos  and cherry and chiles